all right we are live a lot to talk
about a lot to talk about we're gonna
talk about breaking news regarding Trump
Russia indictments and Jeff Sessions
I'll tell you what Amazon is doing to
try to shut the entire thing down I
spoke about it yesterday on the program
a little bit it looks sort of like our
patreon stream Labs things are now
working because I am just seeing a ton
of patreon pledges coming in with the
animation is anybody else seeing that it
seems like it's working I've been trying
to get this thing working last time on
the stream it didn't work and Wow
there's another one that this is crazy
it seems to be working
socata Slavic Kendall has pledged $2 via
patreon John Moeller has pledged to this
is fun I like this has pledged $2 via
patreon I don't exactly know what's
going on I don't know that all of these
are happening now it might be pledges
that happen today I'm not really sure
there's another Peter Brown $1 via
patreon yeah I don't think that these
pledges are actually coming in as we're
talking but it seems to be working and
that's cool I like that okay let's take
a pause from that ain't so far quadruple
nine pledging $5 via patreon okay thank
you very much if this is your first
David Pakman show live stream it's
really live unless you're watching and
replay and you might be watching a
replay if it's not 6:30 3 p.m. Eastern
Time right now on November 1st use super
chat & stream labs to send questions or
comments I will answer your questions I
will read and react to your comments
super chat is the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window Stream lives
comm slash the david pakman show is
where you can send the stream labs
contributions new members and patrons
will get live thank-yous during the
stream david pakman.com slash membership
for membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show for patreon and big news
announced this on the program today we
now accept cryptocurrency
we now accept crypto crypto car
see Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin at
david pakman.com slash cryptocurrency
you can check out our addresses for
three of the for those three crypto
currencies and it's a very very exciting
thing and lastly please don't troll the
live chat if you are seen obviously
trolling or sending hateful comments
then you are going to be blocked banned
timed out whatever by the moderators who
have been deputized and are absolutely
encouraged encouraged to keep the peace
in the chat okay so before we get into
the the latest Russia stuff actually
let's just get into the Russia stuff why
don't we Jeff Sessions is where my focus
is increasingly going so let's set the
scene months ago we had Jeff Sessions
under oath during his attorney general
confirmation hearings tell Al Franken
that he's completely unaware of any
Russian contacts that he was not
involved in any Russian contacts and
just kind of like Russia what that
doesn't really make any sense
we had suspicions we had suspicions that
Jeff Sessions may have committed perjury
in answering Al Franken's questions but
we didn't really have proof and in any
case even if we had what we might
colloquially think of as proof or
evidence that he perjured himself
perjury is rarely prosecuted
particularly because it is very very
difficult to prove definitively so we
kind of forgot about it and said yeah
he's a liar like most of the people
who've involved with Trump but it's not
really going to go any further on Monday
we had George pot we learned of George
papadopolis not only indictment but also
guilty plea for lying to FBI
investigators related to the Trump
Russia investigation and that much more
so than the indictments of Paul Manafort
and Rick gates have exposed way more
lies from others involved with the
Donald Trump administration not the
least of which is what we've learned
about Jeff Sessions because we now have
a situation where we have learned
not only not only was Jeff sessions in
the room with Donald Trump and George
papadopolis
when George papadopolis showed up and
said hey I've got Russian connections
and I can put you guys in touch right so
that alone which I discussed on today's
program would be enough to make us think
well hold on a second
if sessions was in the room when that
happened and that was before Al Franken
asked him about Russian contacts then
it's very hard to believe that Jeff
Sessions genuinely didn't remember the
fact that Russian contacts were proposed
and discussed we have now learned from
CNN this morning and this is the level
to which this would be potentially a
presidency ending scandal if it happened
under President Obama but it is barely a
blip in the constant scandal of the
Trump administration it's stunning we
now learned that not only was Jeff
Sessions in the room when George
papadopolis said hey I've got Russian
contacts they want to meet
representatives of Putin do you want me
to set it up it was apparently Jeff
Sessions who said I don't think that
that's a good idea Jeff Sessions
personally if the report is to be
believed was the one who decided not to
pursue the Russian meetings that George
papadopolis offered up now you can
already if you're thinking about this
you know exactly where the Trump
administration and the defenders of
Trump are going to go with this right
they will be presented with this
evidence and they will say hey what's
the problem Jeff Sessions said it's a
bad idea to meet with the Russians that
is a straw man that is a red herring the
issue is was Jeff Sessions lying in his
confirmation hearing when Al Franken
asked him about Russian contacts it's
fine for Jeff Sessions to Pat himself on
the back he had a I guess the common
sense to say hey you know what maybe we
shouldn't be meeting with the Russians
but the point is that is it makes it
abundantly clear that he was lying that
he was lying when he said I don't know
anything about Russian contacts couldn't
tell you a thing about it and we will
see if this actually goes anywhere I
think there's a couple different ways
this work this could
and I'm gonna flesh these out on the
program tomorrow one way that it could
go is Donald Trump throw sessions under
the bus and says hey we learned about
this from the George papadopolis
indictment and I have asked for Jeff
Sessions his resignation now the reason
that that's going to be very
transparently bogus is that Trump was
also in the room that day Trump and
Papadopoulos and Jeff Sessions were all
in the room on march 31st 2016 for that
meeting so for Trump to say I learned
about the fact that Jeff Sessions was
involved and knew about it from the
Papadopoulos indictment would be
completely transparently unbelievable
because Trump was also in the room and
we have real questions about if and how
that implicates Donald Trump I think
Jeff session I think Robert Muller has
an interest in Jeff Sessions staying on
as Attorney General for a couple
different reasons number one if Jeff
Sessions goes that could put Robert
Moeller's investigation in jeopardy
because if sessions goes Trump either
makes Rod Rosenstein Attorney General
and then Rosenstein who is not recused
on Russia could fire Robert Moeller or
Trump could maybe try to bring in you
know another attorney general although I
mean think ahead to that confirmation
process for a moment who also could
potentially try to get rid of Robert
Muller so a number of different
questions here and I don't I don't have
the answers to a lot of these but it is
really ramping up incredibly quickly
incredibly quickly thanks to corey tracy
for pledging $2 via patreon I appreciate
that
by the way I have no idea whatsoever
what's going on with all of these
animations here because we've had a
handful of pledges on patreon since the
stream started but there's been like 50
animations so far RL pledging $2 via
patreon thank you so much I think the
fact that they're showing up down here
but not up here tells us that this is
sort of like some kind of backlog of
patreon contributions Luiz Iglesias
thank you very much I don't know what to
tell you but I think we have good news
and we have bad news here the good news
is I seem to have fix the problem where
patron
pledges were not showing up as
animations when they happened the
problem is that I think it's possible
that all 1955 current patreon pledges
are gonna be showing up via animation at
some point during the livestream and on
that note David Cooley thank you very
much let me break from that and tell you
who actually has pledged during the
livestream Klauss and 54 has made $1
pledge on patreon
Mickey Platte Co has pledged $5 on
patreon and mr. elk has pledged $5 on
patreon so thank you to those folks and
a couple of new members to welcome as
well
Francis Yancey Francis Yancey has made a
$6 membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and brian kuba sack or kuba
sack or kuba shaq I'm not sure how it's
pronounced has also signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and brian
opting to use the 40% discount code
I voted 17 which is very very exciting
no doubt whatsoever so I I don't know
what's going on I think that these
animations are here to stay we should
only be about 1900 of these away from it
wrapping up so we'll just we'll just
have to sit through it I'm doing math if
we have one every 10 seconds that's 6 a
minute so 1900 should take oh I don't
know about seven years so that's the
that's the upside hmm Lea Weisman thank
you for that contribution okay let me
talk about what's going on with Amazon
there are people who are asking
questions in the chat about what is
happening with Amazon and I will tell
you exactly what is happening with
Amazon for seven years we used to be
part of the Amazon affiliate program as
a result what would happen and this is
the these the way that this has happened
to a lot of programs is pretty
disturbing people would use our Amazon
affiliate link which was located at
david pakman.com slash amazon it would
redirect them to amazon and when you
bought something we would get a little
bit
money from that okay so for example if
you spent a hundred bucks on Amazon
we might get five and over the years
there were lots of people who had that
link bookmarked so they might be people
who were not typing it in every single
time but they had that link bookmarked
and this accumulated to represent
somewhere around ten percent of david
pakman show revenue now ordinarily
getting our link shut down and losing
ten percent of our revenue would not be
life-altering so to speak but we're also
dealing with YouTube D monetization ad
pocalypse as of March 31st which cut
like 45 percent of our revenue so
yesterday or the day before I got notice
that Amazon decided to shut down our
affiliate link because as they say we
were in virally violation of the terms
and conditions of how that's supposed to
be used and that's a big problem for us
that's a big problem now we weren't
banned from the Amazon affiliate program
we immediately reapplied and you now
when you go to david pakman.com slash
amazon you're redirected through a
different affiliate link and I am no
longer telling people to bookmark it and
who knows if this will last or not but
needless to say everybody who had the
link bookmarked which is hundreds or
even thousands of people
the bookmarked link no longer works
because the affiliate code has changed
so needless to say it is not a good
situation and that's part of why we've
been increasingly talking about patreon
and talking about these other sources of
funding because we've got to now make up
not only the 45% of our total revenue
that we lost through YouTube and we were
sort of clawing our way up and we had
recovered about 60% of that lost revenue
now we've got this other 10% from Amazon
that has disappeared
is there an upside yeah kind of I mean I
think that the upside is that anytime we
can eliminate a middleman in terms of
the financial relationship between the
audience and us so with the Amazon
affiliate thing people were buying
things on Amazon and then we were
getting some percentage of that with
patreon and with membership yes there's
a payment processor in between but that
exists even if you go
a store and you give them your credit
card they're still working through a
payment processor so it's a much more
direct relationship and I think that
that's a good thing so if we can recover
all of that lost money then as I've said
before I think we will be in an even
stronger position than we were before
any of this stuff started so on that
note if you do want to replace that
Amazon link and you just want to replace
a dollar a month you can do that at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
do have something very exciting
happening on the program it might start
tomorrow it might start Monday which is
we are going to be doing a patreon Jenga
challenge Jenga of course is this game
with wooden blocks where you stack them
up in sort of overlapping perpendicular
groups of three and then the idea is you
start removing Jenga blocks and placing
them on top and eventually the entire
thing topples over and whoever topples
it loses is the way it goes we are going
to be setting up a Jenga game I guess on
the studio desk at David Pakman show
studios and for every patreon
contribution that is made and it doesn't
matter when they're made we're just
gonna keep a tally we will be saying we
will be moving one piece for each person
and we will see how many pieces can be
moved one per patreon contribution
before the entire thing topples over and
then whatever that number is we will
create a coupon code with that
percentage off so if we're able to make
46 Jenga moves before the thing topples
then we'll create some kind of Jenga
related coupon code and you will get 46
percent off in membership if you want
now it we already know we've already
discussed internally the funniest
possible thing that could happen is this
is going to be on the studio desk that I
sit at during the show and I sometimes
get animated I sometimes punch my mic I
sometimes put my hands down hard the
best possible thing that could happen is
for me to accidentally knock over the
entire Jenga thing during the taping of
the show so in any case that it we are
officially starting now right so any
patreon
starting from now going forward we will
keep track of them and we will say this
is the Jenga piece that's being moved
because of the contribution of in this
case Jason Moore I think was the last or
Alexis Portillo whose animation just
showed up there for a contribution so
it's gonna be happening it's gonna be
happening and it's very very exciting
stuff and the reason we're doing this is
we've been having this problem where we
build up last night October 31st we were
actually up to 2009 patrons we had
surpassed 2,000 and on the first of the
month patreon goes to charge every
active patron and as often happens
during any month if you've got 2,000
people with their debit or credit card
information connected to patreon some of
those people's credit cards have expired
and they've not updated the payment
information some of those people's
credit cards you know they get declined
charges etc so we were immediately
knocked down from 2009 patrons to
something like 1935 and close to 20
people have already rican tributed today
so the first of the month is always kind
of depressing on patreon but Kyle
Morrissey is back in there with a $2.00
contribution and that we can all
appreciate okay let's jump into let's
jump into Opie Pulaski what if we get
$2.99 Jenga piece Jenga moves before it
topples how can we give a hundred
percent discount off of membership
wouldn't happen because I believe a
Jenga board agenda game only has 54 so
it seems like it would max out at 54 and
yeah I guess well it can you could make
more than 54 moves if they start being
stacked no you couldn't really I guess
you couldn't that doesn't make sense
anyway clearly we don't know what we're
doing but that's what we're doing and
we'll see what happens okay let's jump
into some of the super chats here Theo H
has sent a $5 super chat are you worried
about the investigation appearing rushed
with the indictments coming less than
six months after Moeller took over well
you mean fewer than six months after
Moeller took over but grammar nazi' them
aside no I'm not I
that you Robert molar is not the type of
guy that seems to work haphazardly and I
think that he went with the indictments
he went with so far specifically because
these are really strong cases he has
Paul Manafort and yay
Ric Ric Gates dead to rights and he is
strategically and ighting them now to
send a signal to maybe other
co-conspirators and also to try to put
pressure on those individuals to flip
because Robert Muller must believe at
least to some degree that they might
have very damaging information about
other Trump associates so I'm not
worried about that at all
Theo Klaus and 54 have sent a 5 euro
super chat I ditched patreon in favor of
membership now that I realize how much I
want the college lectures back in and
doing both keep up the great work
yeah that some people might not be aware
of that thanks Matt by the way for that
contribution the goal that's visible
right now on patreon is 2,000 patrons
and when we get to 2,000 patrons and and
stay there for more than an hour before
we lost something like 70 patrons
overnight when we get to 2,000 I'll do a
full broadcast show from the studio with
my hair like this ok but once that's
accomplished we will move on to the 2500
patron goal and that is the goal which
will be the production and publication
of a dozen college lectures 75 minute
long-form lectures on critical thinking
and media literacy and epistemology and
and logical fallacies that will happen
at the 2,500 patron level so I
appreciate that Klaus glad to have you
back on patreon
Jamal Swift has sent the $10 super chat
love the show but can I get smoother
transitions in your YouTube clips when
cutting to advertisers otherwise your
show is perfect
okay you know what Jamal because we aim
to please
I will make a note right now to talk to
Pat tomorrow who handles the editing
about a smoother transition I'll make a
note right
now I only have 62 items on my to-do
list tomorrow so what is one more
especially if it will improve the
audience experience pat nam advertiser
transitions youtube ok I'm personally
gonna be handling that for you
my pleasure Aaron Cohen sent the 5
Canadian dollar super chat your take on
if Papadopoulos wore a wire over the
past few months also over under 900 days
this whole thing concludes alla
Watergate keep up the great work I don't
know about 900 days but what I made very
clear was that it was almost two years
between the first Watergate indictments
in the resignation of Richard Nixon so
we've just had our first indictments I
guess really the first one was in early
october with george papadapolis even
though that was kept sealed until yes
the day before yesterday I don't know
about 900 days but I believe that
Papadopoulos did wear a wire in
everything I've read in all the legal
commentary that I've looked at the term
proactive collaborator was used and all
of the legal analyses I've read indicate
that a proactive collaborator is someone
that was very likely to be wearing a
wire and was as the term suggests
proactively going out there to gather
possible incriminating intelligence and
information so I believe that he was
wearing wire and I am very interested in
seeing what it is that ultimately comes
from that over at stream labs.com / the
david pakman show sandy 7em has sent a
$5 contribution no question nor comment
but thank you very much sandy I really
appreciate that great to see you back in
but Robert Ceja has pledged $2 via
patreon and I appreciate that very very
much and we continue if you're just
joining us last livestream I thought
that it had these animations down here
all set up for when people make patreon
contributions and and they weren't
working correctly that was the that was
the sad thing and it appears as though
that's been fixed but it's possible that
the system now is running through all
1950 whatever patreon
that are currently active so we are
getting quite a show here and I don't
know how long it's going to go on can
natkho for example made a $5 pledge via
patreon and we love Han we love
everybody who's pledging but I these
these animations are out of control and
is there a sound playing with every
single one of those because I think that
if I let me see here
I'm unmuting my laptop let me see if a
sound plays whenever one of those comes
up wow I'm getting a noise a chime I'm
gonna turn that off because I could get
pretty annoying can people tell me in
the chat whether they are getting chimes
I hear no sound no sound no sound that
is odd why am I getting a sound and
nobody else's I hear the sounds now
there is sound no well so what you were
hearing was my speakers going into my
microphone see if I unmute let's see if
we get another one hmm Scott hunter
didn't make a sound what's the next one
coming up who's next
there it is so that was through my
speakers so if you heard that
that's weird if I'm getting it I don't
know why you wouldn't but listen I don't
know that we'll ever really figure it
out okay khari 99 has sent the super
chat thoughts on switching our voting
system to a blockchain structure same
technology as Bitcoin this would make
voting unhackable
I made a petition for this yeah that
that's beyond where I'm ready to go
khari I think that we should be moving
to Instant Runoff voting I think that we
should be you know I've talked about the
specific changes I would make to the
voting system but I'm not ready to say
go over to blockchain what I am ready to
tell you is that we now accept
cryptocurrency very seamless transition
if you go to david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency or look in the video
description for this live stream or any
other david pakman show videos you will
notice our Bitcoin aetherium and
litecoin addresses and people have
already been making
contributions through those platforms
and it's absolutely and utterly
tremendous and I'm glad we did it we've
been we've been thinking about it for a
while and we've done it and now we are
receiving Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin
which is a really really great thing we
have not yet figured out how to be able
to pay for membership on a recurring
basis through cryptocurrency but we we
actually do have people exploring that
and it is a little more difficult than
some in our audience believed it to be
some people reached out and said here's
how you do it David I explained to them
why we can't do that
and we're working on a solution but at
least for now we are fully enabled to
receive cryptocurrency contributions and
I know a lot of people like that okay
what did I want to go to next I had a
whole number of different agenda items
tomorrow I'm going to be interviewing
dr. Robert Lustig that is a guest that
people have been recommending for a
while and there's really no good reason
why we haven't interviewed him already
except that you know we have guests all
the time and you can't make everything
happen immediately but tomorrow on the
program dr. Robert Lustig will be
joining us he is one of the first sort
of advocates of not he developed the
idea in popular culture of metabolic
syndrome which is really a number of
different conditions that he believes
are related to excessive sugar sugar
consumption in diet and he has a new
book hacking the hacking the American
diets and now if I do know it I didn't
research it but I'm just not remembering
offhand
let's see Robert Lustig the new book is
hacking of the American mind that is
what it is and he is going to be talking
to us tomorrow and I'm really looking
forward to that that's gonna be a
fantastic interview we are putting the
finishing touches on the race and IQ
long-form video which is going to be
really really good we'll be interviewing
next week mark Godsey mark Godsey is
involved with the Ohio Innocence Project
innocence projects are these legal
advocacy groups that help to exonerate
pee
who have been sentenced to prison but
are not guilty or believed to be not
guilty and he has been involved in 25
over turnings of wrongful convictions
for people who served a combined four
hundred and seventy years and he's got a
new book called blind and justice we'll
be talking to him
Monday and Tuesday Wednesday Luke Vargas
is going to be checking in with us from
South Korea he is going to be with
President Trump and what that exactly
means I don't know but he's going he's
gonna be traveling at least with the
press corps and he is going to be
checking in from South Korea about
what's going on there and then on
Thursday we will what is have no
interview Thursday because I will be
broadcasting remotely next Thursday so
we've got a really good week plan we're
booked almost all the way out to
Thanksgiving at this point that is how
far ahead some of these interviews are
being booked and it's a really good
thing we're getting more and more
requests for interviews over at stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show how
psy has sent a $4 contribution saying
this isn't a robot it may very well may
have hydraulic arms a drive chain and a
circuit board but this isn't a robot
this is a lesson in humility hard work
and collaboration this is a CrossFit
workout for the muscle upstairs this is
how psy 9000 okay a very unusual comment
but a comment that I have read
nonetheless so thank you thank you for
that house I appreciate that
and thanks to Claudio Baumbach she who
has pledged $2 via patreon and I really
appreciate that and the patreon
contributions at least as far as those
little animations down there a concern
continue to roll in a meal faux
Christensen has made a $2 pledge via
patreon thank you I really appreciate
that
those were trying to build back up to
the 2009 contributions that we had
achieved yesterday and James O'Hagan is
helping us do that with a $2 pledge and
that's fantastic that is
absolutely fantastic what else am I
going to be talking about on the program
tomorrow we will be talking about the
investigation that supposedly is taking
place into that puerto rican power
contract i absolutely love this we saw
this tiny company Whitefish energy get a
300 million dollar contract to restore
puerto rican power and right away it
seemed weird because they had only two
full-time employees they were in
Whitefish Montana and it didn't really
make sense that they would get that
contract and then we found out it just
so happens Trump's interior secretary
Ryan Zinke is from Whitefish Montana
even though he denies having had any
involvement in that contract being
issued we then found out that the
company that is financing Whitefish
Energy has some major Trump donors in
their ranks and Puerto Rico decided to
cancel the contract it was a total swamp
filling it was a swamp job right filling
the swamp with a fire hose not draining
it and then I said well that's great and
that's the right move but I would
actually like to see this contract
investigated because it seemed really
really shady and there are now reports
although they have not yet the FBI says
they're not confirming nor denying that
they are investigating that deal and
there could be agencies other than the
FBI that could also get involved and we
don't know the full full extent of it
but there are reports that now there is
an investigation into Whitefish energy
can you imagine you're one of the two
full-time employees or the company
that's financing Whitefish energy and
you just got this 300 million dollar
deal the the donations to Trump paid off
it all paid off you got the 300 million
dollar deal everything's great and then
the deal gets cancelled and then you're
now under potential FBI investigation
amazing right i mean it's it's i usually
very naive about justice actually being
served in the American justice system
but it's possible that it might be and
that would be a really really great
thing so we're going to talk about that
on tomorrow's program unless something
crazy happens on Twitter at 3:00 a.m.
and I'm also going to talk about
cross-check a lot of you have been
saying David you've got to talk about
the cross-check system that is purging
people from the voter rolls I have a
report
hopefully for you tomorrow because it's
such an important story about how in
Indiana cross-check has purged 99%
incorrectly 99% of the people purged
from voter rolls by the cross-check
system in Indiana have been purged
incorrectly and we're going to be
talking about that as well as how 50% of
Donald Trump's Senate confirmed nominees
have conflicts of interest within the
industries that they're supposed to be
regulating right so Trump nominates
people to work in regulation of certain
industries and it turns out that those
people have conflicts of interest within
those exact same industries amazing
right a stream labs.com slash david
pakman show
Christina sent a $2.00 question how do
you handle moments when you're feeling
very overwhelmed by stress how do you
calm down
or cheer yourself up I'm not much for
cheering myself up my mood is pretty
regular but I think that what I try to
do is either exercise or meditate
those are it those are my big things can
I go for a run can I go for a swim can I
meditate for 20 minutes those are those
are the things I try to do Ray Merrill
has sent a thirteen dollar and 25 cent
contribution at stream labs.com
slash the David Pakman show I'm always
interested how people come up with some
of these contribution numbers 13:25
thank you no question or comment from
Ray but I do appreciate that and on that
note I do want to recognize the top
all-time contributors at stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show in first
place according to dollars is Eric
Patterson who has contributed two
hundred and fifty four dollars through
stream labs comm slash the David Pakman
show
in second place is Clark one two three
four and in third place is Christina now
in terms of the number of contributions
Christina is at the top of the list with
thirty four contributions on stream labs
and Clark one two three four with thirty
three contributions a couple people tied
low that so thanks to everybody the
advantage for those who don't know of
stream labs over super chat is super
chat takes about 30% I believe it's
exactly 30% and stream labs takes only
the something like 3% processing fee so
that's that's a good thing let's go to
super chat lean dirt I believe it's die
cows sent a five Australian dollar super
chat us has gotten more divided in the
past decade what do you think it takes
to get people United and talking to each
other again I wish I knew I don't even
have a speculative answer for you lean
dirt I think that you know part of this
is that we increasingly don't have
elected officials that are actually
representing the views of the public we
have elected officials that are
increasingly representing the views of
big corporations and rich people and
that is going to predispose people of
all political backgrounds to believe
that they need to be more extreme in
their views in order to maybe get
anything to actually happen I think that
that's part of it I think that the fact
that our politicians our elected
officials are almost permanently angling
for their next reelection drastically
impacts how politics is done everything
always has to be how can I turn this
into a wedge issue around which I can
raise money I think that's a factor so I
think that there's a number of issues
going on here simultaneously they
overlap but I don't I don't have a good
answer for you in terms of what it takes
to to fix the problem sadly let me do a
couple thank-yous here we did just
receive a $2 patreon contribution from
Adam Bollinger Adam Bollinger has made a
$2 patreon contribution and I really
really appreciate that we also have a
couple of new members that I want to
welcome and say hello to the first of
which is Becky Russo Becky thanks for
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership also Thomas MacDonald Thomas
MacDonald has signed up at david
pakman.com
komm slash membership and Tracy Smith
has also signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership there is a coupon code
available to you it is
I voted 17 if you want 40% off take 40%
off and that is available to you at all
times people who came in late asking
what is what exactly has Amazon done to
you David what is going on well we used
to earn about 10 percent of our revenue
through our Amazon affiliate link and
the way that worked was when folks like
you would make a purchase on Amazon
through our affiliate link we would get
a cut of that it started at 4 percent
early in the month and as more items
were purchased it would work its way all
the way up to 8 percent that's real
money when you've got hundreds or
thousands of people with that link
bookmarked and I like many other
progressive shows and other shows that
use this as a fundraising tool we were
by the letter of Amazon's Terms of
Service in violation and the Terms of
Service are very very broad and Amazon
has started to shut down a lot of
affiliate links and we were the latest
we were hit Monday evening I believe it
was and we've lost another 10% of our
revenue so that's why we are pushing
patreon that's why we're pushing
membership we just got to make that up
and I think the the upside in the long
run and thank you to Chris Soares with a
$10 patreon pledge the upside in the
long run is any revenue that we can
build independent of systems like
somebody buying products on Amazon it's
a good thing right it's a good thing it
was good while it lasted but it's done
and we are now accepting contributions
via cryptocurrency we're trying to build
patreon we are trying to build
membership and that's what's going on
that's the long and short of it let's
get back to super chests Juan Garcia
Juan Garcia has sent a $5 super check
what are your thoughts on tulsi gabbard
as a potential candidate in the 2020
election 1 you know that you are a david
pakman show all-star who calls in you
contribute via super chat you do the
entire thing but I am NOT talking about
2020 presidential can
right now I have made the decision that
it does not make sense to get involved
in that right now because I think any
attention we take away from the fact
that we have special elections in 2017
in the midterms in 2018 I am NOT ready
tulsi gabbard seems like a fantastic
person absolutely tremendous person but
I am NOT ready to comment on Tulsi
Gabbard as a possible presidential
candidate Green has sent a dollar stream
labs contribution at stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show the question
is will there be more live in studio
interviews in the future you know it's
not that we don't want in studio
interviews it's two things number one
most of our guests are not in Boston and
number two if we're doing a 15-minute
interview and the guest is in Boston I
still kind of feel bad having them drive
all the way to our studio for a 15
minute interview and I know corporate
media does it all the time when I lived
in New York they would send a car for me
drive me depending on traffic 25 to 45
or an hour uptown to CNN studios or Fox
News Studios prepped me for 45 minutes I
would sit around and then it might be
like a four minute interview and then
I'd have to drive be driven as they set
it up all the way back home to Brooklyn
and it just seemed like kind of a waste
of time and I get that the dynamic is
different and sometimes more interesting
when the guest is in studio so I'm not
against it it has to be the right
situation I think the best thing would
be if somebody like former President
Barack Obama were coming through Boston
as he sometimes does I think it would be
fantastic to have him into our studio
let's do an hour interview but I don't
know that that is necessarily going to
be happening anytime soon
Clarke one two three four has sent a $5
stream lapse contribution saying I if
you really want to support David give to
stream labs instead of super chat so
Google takes 30% of all super chat money
don't let Google [ __ ] David any more
than they already have just this for
David all right well a powerful and
inspiring message of strength
perseverance and equality I don't know
what I'm talking about from cloth one
two three four thank you very much I
think that that is a really really great
mess
which cloth and I appreciate you sending
it out to people because it's it's an
important message and it is a relevant
message and that's a really really good
thing oh let me make a general
announcement about long-form pieces I am
always interested in hearing from you
about what issues you want us to take a
look at in a longer form analysis 20 25
30 minutes the race and IQ piece I
believe is going to end up being two
15-minute segments about a half hour on
race and IQ and we delve into the
history of people who started to try to
make analyses connecting race and IQ we
talk about the bell curve we talk about
the science behind it's a really really
good piece that's the next one and we
always have a long list let me actually
tell you what else why don't I do this
why not right I'll pull up the list of
other possible our short list of
long-form videos that we have right now
and see if anything strikes you as
interesting so race and IQ is in
production we've got the critical
thinking miniseries they're script is is
mostly done but it's 98% there we need
to think about how to do it I actually
had the idea that the critical thinking
miniseries which would be about 15 or 20
parts could be done and this is separate
from my college lectures by the way it
would be great to do them as whiteboard
videos but I got a quote from a couple
different people they said it would be
like five to six thousand dollars for
the whiteboard videos and it just
doesn't you know it's it's we're not
gonna make that back and particularly
with what's going on with the
monetization and Amazon shutdown it's
not like we've got six grand to spare
right now so that doesn't make sense but
if someone in the audience has an idea
or would want to work on that with us or
something that's 98 percent done we just
need the technical side and I think
whiteboard videos would be really cool
but they are expensive to produce a
video on Godwin's law
Godwin's law is the it's a sort of it's
it's an idea that the longer a
conversation happens on
the internet the more likely it is that
someone makes an analogy to Nazism and
the idea that I had was when can we say
that something is like Nazis Hitler or
the Third Reich that's an idea I had a
cryptocurrency explainer a video
explaining how cryptocurrency works what
the blockchain is with regard to Bitcoin
specifically that's an idea for a
long-form piece how white nationalism
becomes normalized I think that that's
an interesting one universal health care
right a deeper dive into universal
health care and how different countries
set up these systems and how it could
work it's kind of wonky kind of dry but
it could be interesting and maybe a
long-form investigation into the war on
drugs okay those are the those are the
that's the short list right now and that
doesn't mean that we can't make it a
bigger list that we absolutely can
doesn't mean that we can't pick
something else to work on next but race
and IQ is the one that's currently in
production and then we have these other
ones that I mentioned which which I
think I think there's a lot there but we
just have to decide so if you have ideas
two ways to communicate them number one
is you can just email in through the
website contact form the other
possibility is that there is a thread on
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash read it and you can put
your ideas in there I do check that
regularly it's still still alive and I
would encourage you to check that out if
you have any ideas for long-form pieces
on that note let me do a couple other
thank-yous here we have a new member
Mike Rocha who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Mike thank
you thank you thank you thank you what
else can I say
Mike Rocha is a great person and is even
greater because they've signed up for a
membership I also have a new patron I
want to say thank you too and that is
Austin long who has pledged two dollars
and 50 cents per month and I really
appreciate that the world-famous bonus
show is both a member and patron benefit
any membership or a patreon contribution
of five dollars a month gets you access
to the bonus show and we've told some
great great stories on the bonus show
and I encourage you to check it out it's
a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing okay George cook
also pledging three dollars via patreon
if you're just coming in and you're
wondering what on earth is that why do
all those names keep coming up I don't
know we use stream labs to generate all
these graphics during the live stream
and the last live stream I did Stream
Labs have a patreon integration and it
said hey you can sync up your patreon
account and now you will be able to
display on screen when somebody makes a
patreon contribution and that's a really
beautiful thing now on Monday it didn't
work and people were upset today it
seems like it's working but what appears
to be happening is that every single one
of the nearly 2,000 page contributions
is cycling through here and I mean it's
crazy right the entire time I've been
talking the Super Mario animation is
going and it's insane and the reason I
think that it is still malfunction is is
because it's supposed to show up up here
and down here but they're only showing
up down there I don't know what to tell
you it's very very odd it is very very
odd and I don't know if it's distracting
to people at this point I don't even
know that I could turn it off like a
virus we might need to let it run its
course and ultimately it will stop I
guess I don't know what to tell you and
let me see if the noise is still
happening if I unmute my computer there
it is yeah I don't get that other people
say they're not hearing that but I'm
hearing it and it's very very odd very
very odd I don't know what to tell you
okay what is happening people starting
to wonder will we be taking a
three-month vacation at the end of the
year well we don't have three months
left in the year so that's not going to
happen but we are going to be taking
what are we taking for Thanksgiving well
for Thanksgiving we're going to be
taking Thursday and Friday off so we'll
Thanksgiving off and the day after
Thanksgiving that's what that's what we
normally do and that week the Wednesday
show will be like a Friday show right so
the format of the Wednesday show
Thanksgiving week which is three weeks
away will be like a Friday show with
life calls and all of that stuff and
then at the end of the year let's take a
look at the calendar we've got this sort
of perfect timing
we're both Christmas and New Year's are
wrapped right around weekends where we
have the eaves on a Sunday and the days
on a Monday so I believe that what we're
going to do is close out the year with a
vacation week I think that's what we're
going to do I think it's as I've said
before important for staff to get
vacation time I think in the United
States there's just not enough vacation
time taken so that's the direction I'm
leaning in as a heads up for what's
coming up for the end of the year
adjacent Brown 12 has sent a $2 super
chat David what do you think will happen
to daca I think that the conditions of
daca will ultimately remain although it
might be one of these things where daca
is replaced with something else with a
different name to appear to be a
political victory even though they're
not really going to start deporting kids
who came here before they were adults to
the United States that that's the most
likely scenario for me but you know a
desperate Trump he's liable to do
anything so I don't know I that that
that seems to be like the most likely
scenario although there's any other
there's any number of other ish other
things that could come up that would
change that and we will ultimately have
to wait and see Cristina has sent a
dollar stream lapse contribution the
sound is your alert a donation has been
made to you oh that's interesting in
other words am i hearing this sound take
a listen to it we missed it with Pam
Ferguson
here we go three two one go there it is
am i hearing that because the donation
has been made to me and that's why no
one else is hearing it I guess maybe
yeah I guess that's right I guess that's
right I'm not gonna leave that on I'm
not gonna leave that on for you because
that seems to be incredibly annoying you
I think you're making you're making a
lot of sense okay let me say thank you
to a new patron Robert Venice has made a
$2.00 per month pledge at patreon.com
slash David Pakman show
thank you Robert thank you so much if
you missed it at the beginning of the
stream we are going to be I believe that
this is starting tomorrow at David
Pakman show studios we are going to be
setting up Jenga visibly on the studio
desk next to me and for every patreon
contribution I will announce the name of
the patron remove a Jenga piece and put
it on the top and the goal will be that
as many Jenga moves as I can make one
for each patreon contribution when the
Jenga pile ultimately Falls or when the
Jenga tower ultimately falls into a pile
that number of moves will be turned into
a membership coupon code the best
possible thing would be I think for the
up from the point of view the audience
if when we're not making Jenga moves
merely because I punch my mic or shake
the desk the entire thing topples over
and I think we should have a provision
where if that happens for like an hour
we do a 70% off membership or something
like that I think that that would be
fair right because there needs to be
some we need to gamify the entire thing
so anyway up starting tonight during the
livestream anybody who makes
contribution so robert venice or whoever
else you're part of it so whenever the
Jenga thing comes in I will start making
moves with your names included in that
so very very exciting stuff to look
forward to isn't there ok let's get to a
couple of other contributions that came
in
here I believe it was was it over at
stream labs I missed one yes there was
one from a user going by the name of
Louis Motamedi who sent a dollar stream
labs contribution saying Louis Motamedi
has become a patreon supporter there you
go now whether that is or isn't the real
Louis Motamedi I can't tell you except
that I can tell you it's not because I
know exactly which user it is but I
won't tell you let's pretend that that
might actually be the real louis MO
tommy just for a moment okay my I'm
having a major problem here with my
internet connection and I know that I
often have a delay of sorts and
sometimes my screen will go blue
but it seems to be particularly bad
today and I don't know why it is we're
not having a weather issue I'm on wired
Internet there's really no reason that
that should be going on so I apologize
for that and on that note I hope I don't
get disconnected I hope I don't get
disconnected okay live calls there's
been a lot of questions about live calls
and whether we deliberately don't pick
up on adversarial phone calls that is
literally impossible unless it's
somebody who's called in the past
because all I see during live calls is
phone numbers and I can sometimes
remember area codes that people
regularly call from but I don't even
look beyond the area code so it's it's
literally not possible for me to people
people noticing that the patreon updates
are getting a little bit crazy it's not
possible for me to prevent adversarial
calls from getting on it's just not we
have not been getting that many
adversarial calls we've gotten a couple
trolling calls we've gotten a few NiO
pucks as all cause I'm as I'm calling
them but we really are not getting that
many adversarial phone calls and I would
love adversarial phone calls but call me
and challenge me on policy don't just
call up with you you know ad hominem x'
or that type of thing because that's
quite boring
that's quite boring okay I'm going to be
wrapping up today's live stream now
should I just let it run
and allow these patreon updates to
continue I don't know that if they need
to be sort of worked out of the system
like a release valve or something like
that before we will actually see today's
contributors show up right over here but
I don't know if I should just keep the
livestream rolling with these is that is
that an idea what is that something I
should do I mean it's definitely
concerning because without my
supervision people could make
contributions and they might put
incredibly vile and vulgar stuff up on
the screen but is that really a concern
I mean I think we're mostly adults here
other than the little kids should I just
allow the live stream to continue I
don't know people threatening lawsuits
in the chat but not really talking about
that now you know what I'm not going to
do that I'm not going to do that we will
end the live stream but I will stream
again soon we now accept cryptocurrency
check out our wallet addresses in the
video description